well it's 114
are we on yes we are so hello everyone
thanks for having me here at MDC Oslo
I'm very happy to be here
my name is Cara Zygmunt I work on dotnet
team and I'm gonna tell you something
about war stories from dotnet team where
I have been for last 14 years and a
little disclaimer before we start I
rehearsed the talk this morning and
found out there is lot too much content
so I removed some and then I did Twitter
Paul you know if you you know if you
want advice what do you do you go to
Twitter right and Twitter poll told me
like yep it's better it's better to kind
of pace through so I apologize for some
of those stories that I'm gonna talk
about I'm gonna probe a little bit
faster so just heads up and what I'm
gonna talk about I'm gonna talk about
stories so stories from that I mostly
lived through either directly as a
developer or maybe you know as a manager
that this has been on my team some of
the stories are actually not that I
directed was involved but it's something
from the team and stories that I kind of
think are cool most leaders are some
investigations on.net team run time base
class library something like that and
they're not just for me and hopefully
I'm gonna show you as well or in order
the key to some kind of lessons that we
have learned along the way from some of
these cool and or interesting at least
investigations so what's not on the
agenda you won't see any source code you
won't see any debugger there is one call
stack and that's it so if you if you
expect debugger and source code this is
the wrong talk please leave or don't get
is appointed something like that
and you don't need any deep knowledge of
dotnet I'm gonna explain some of the
concepts but you know if you miss them
that fine
if you are into debugging and advanced
debugging techniques this is the torque
you should have been to yesterday so
those are critter guys Kevin and
Christoph and they did awesome job
between dbg no such stuff over here I'm
gonna start with my first story so my
first serious investigation on dotnet
team happened actually quite early so it
was 2006
I joined 2005 in October so I was three
months in and this investigation kind of
comes in which was pretty fun so it was
some kind of build up
team in Windows some component and
they're building their product and to
set the expectation sorry so to set the
context I was in owner as I joined I was
owner of metadata component part of the
CLR for the right time so they have this
you know you know this built lab you
know dozens of machines you know
crunching builds every night probably
multiple times a day and what happens
like roughly once per week they get a
build break and the build break is
actually access violation dialogue back
then nobody nothing dismissed it so they
had to login on the machine you know
click the ok and restart the bill kind
of like bummer on productivity and so
they started investigating they went
through like oh it must be a mess no
problem so they involved I must build
people a mess bill people said like you
know ok
take out the c-sharp compiler or you
know repro or the command line try that
ok that's in c-sharp let's move it to
c-sharp compiler c-sharp compiler look
at that and they said like yep that's
somewhere in metadata so boom curl you
go that was actually the investigation
before that happened what was funny that
they notice that heavy actually updated
tool set of the CLR of the compiler just
few weeks ago that must be it like you
know we updated to to 2.0 RTM suddenly
it started failing you're it it's your
problem
I was interesting attitude and you know
they were kind of right as you still see
so the good news is that these people
were smart very good and they try to
create a repro for us which is you know
lifesaver so first they tried it and you
know kind of inner loop building the
same stuff over and over again it
Reynaud failed roughly once in 50/50
runs which is great and then ray your
internet overnight and you know you see
some numbers 77 77 thousand iterations
over now overnight actually over weekend
I believe or overnight I don't remember
250 cash 247 crashes so you know some
significant reproducible things so good
we have very Pro before I you know and
out of the repros we actually got call
stack before I showed the call stack
there was some funny quotes actually in
the old emails I found out so the first
one first one basically said that hey it
looks like from the call stack that's
some boilerplate stack checking code is
wrong now I wasn't you know
experience enough free months in the job
right if I saw it today the first thing
would be like alarm alarm this is a you
know security issue as soon as you mess
up it's called wit stack you know
something is wrong and it's gonna bite
you anyway
back then nobody noticed that so we went
on and other funny you know comment you
know rebels into email which basically
you know the person from C sharp team
kind of ping me on I am like what do we
do and I basically set back like you
know yeah this is great
but I'm nuclear code so you gotta help
me you have to you know it may take make
may take some time so they said it as
well to the expectation of Anubis love
it was you know pretty funny nothing
anyway we got the call stack this is the
call stack I removed lines things so
make a little bit more readable at the
bottom you see the c-sharp compiler
higher up you see kind of the as low
c-sharp compiler which is kind of like
emitting metadata and at the top of the
call stack it's us and over there
there's some kind of readwrite lock
which suddenly blows up and AV so
obviously it was not enough luckily we
got like heap dumps so we could look at
the assembly code so that was a great
three days of learning how to use my
latent knowledge of x86 assembly and
figure out like you know what's what the
locals what are the parameters how it
flows and debugging through that it was
lots of fun and great learning
opportunity if you want to run assembly
I recommend some issue like that like
really really useful so first thing on
that you know when you get schools like
like that get heap dumps so it's like
who corrupts the stack and because we
are in the world of managed code like GC
and loop and why not because this is
c-sharp compiler remember this is before
Roslyn even existed or was a thing so it
was all native so GC doesn't even run
right that the parts of the metadata
emitter or metadata reader was actually
you know does the native part of the
code and no GC ever run so no GC wasn't
it when I dug deeper I found it actually
there were you know there was one call
you know on the coast a car up on the
coast I guess we've seen that sudden
some data change like you know on one
hand it was like I'll make it up five
and if you look further down it was four
turns out that it was actually a single
bit change you look at that and say like
who corrupts you know just one single
bit what could it be could it be like GC
car table like updates you know those
are the kind of weird things that set up
things and then like now like we already
said there's no GC in that process so I
was actually good experience of like
myself and as well others first jumping
to conclusions to the known patterns and
then realizing like yeah they are not
quite applicable when you think that
they should be so GC it is not it so
what else could it be could it be like
Hardware flaky like that sounds stupid
right you know why would it be always on
the call stack but maybe maybe yes turns
out that you know it was actually a
hardware issue so I know how I found out
I asked actually the team like so guys
you know bar a chance doesn't reproduce
only on one machine and the answer was
like how did you know well I had a hunch
and then comes the next question so so
long story short probably memory or CPU
whatever but then you know kind of you
think about that it said like you know
so why does it fail always on the same
coast that just doesn't make sense once
per week right or once per iteration the
iterations once for 50 you know what I
don't have good you know it's a good
question why I have no good answer some
magic they took the machine out
everything worked since then so that was
my first investigation on the run time
team which I count found funny and
interesting and which actually taught me
some things and lesson that I learned
mostly from that is the debugging
hardware eros is actually costly and
hard and the key takeaway is that taught
me to ask always one question for
anything which looks fishy weird and
stuff and that's does it repro only on
one machine if the answer is oh we
didn't try it on more machines like okay
I'll stop talking to you you try it on
another machine when you see it on two
machines then we can start talking
there's so now I come over as smart you
know and everything it's not as that you
know
took me actually won more hardware back
to to can of debug and you know waste
like one week or something and then I
finally learned this lesson and honestly
since then that's the first thing I
asked interestingly over my career
actually I ran into one issue which I
don't remember exactly which was
somewhat similar it was actually not
hardware issue but it was some driver
issue so the the symptoms symptoms were
that you got this weird thing happening
but only on certain machines which had
the same I think graphics card or
something with the same driver solution
to that like you know sometimes you
might want to ask or I might want to ask
back hey you know can you try different
hardware just in case you know that you
can really reproduce it and actually
there's one even extreme version of this
if you know Mona Stevens she's our GC
guru for years like she's the she's
awesome GC and when I talked with her
about this story and like how cool it is
she's like look at me and like yeah you
know what I don't even trust VMs this
was like back that's like 10 years ago
whenever someone comes back in oh hey
this is GC back first thing I'm asking
him like you know does it reproduce on
real hardware if you don't have the
answer I'm not even talking to you Oh
obviously sometimes we are right you
know when there's business enough reason
we do but it was funny that the
perspectives are very different and was
in the time it was during the time when
kind of VMs had like still kind of
problems in their drivers and things and
things could get corrupted on behalf of
your process and chasing down GC issues
is extremely difficult so that's how she
shielded herself from that at least for
a while probably she doesn't do it these
days because everything is VM and you
know ask for people to try to reproduce
it on real hardware all right so that's
my first story and because I started in
metadata you know owning the metadata
component I'm gonna continue with
another metadata story for that I'm
gonna first introduce some kind of
background on metadata format we all
need it so metadata in nutshell is
basically describing your program if you
you know if you're not not developer so
hopefully you are you know DLL or
exhibit you have that there are two
parts there's the code the il which is
for Java words is like basically
the bytecode and there's the metadata
which describes ty
who inherits from her what like you know
which method starts at which offset and
those type of things and the metadata is
basically just the database it was
interesting it was invented but for
people who kind of came from database
background so they use the first thing
that they knew and it's a fitting format
actually it has rows it has columns it
has tables example is table of type
deaths which are you know definitions of
types and it in the table we have kind
of rows kind of entry for each type and
each column is something like for
example flags or you have their
information about like type name
namespace you know what it extends or
method list and we're gonna get to that
that's the important part the when you
have references between these tables
they are not for example do strings are
not exactly directly in just in the in
the table the strings are on so called
string heap so on the side and you have
only index into that now the trick is
because back then when it was designed
like 20-plus years ago I believe back
then like you know memory and or size
was very important so there's some kind
of primitive compression basically
saying like oh if the if you're indexing
something which is less than 64 K you
can use only two bytes now if it's more
like okay you gotta use four bytes so
basically statically pair each DLL or
eggsy and you look at that you know it
has information like how many strings do
we do I have how many you know methods I
have how many types do I have and based
on that those those indexes are for
specific references either two bytes or
four bytes so what can go wrong with
that all right sorry skip too far so I
need to invest first in a you know want
to explain what the method list means
here so each type has some methods
usually and the method list is a smart
way how to basically saying like hey
here's my first method and there's a
list and it goes on and goes down on
either until end of the table or until
the next type method list starts so in
this example we have we have met at
least you know method number 10 on type
full and type bar has starts
method 11 which means that the type type
fool has only one method and it's going
to be the method number 10 at index 10
hopefully clear so what happens if the
last type def let's say the type bar in
this case doesn't have any methods what
do you do if you look at the spec I'm
gonna show it even later you basically
suppose to to kind of point it to the
plus one so the next one that doesn't
exist so when you look up the method
list you go to the to the index of
method you see oh this is the one that
doesn't exist because I have only let's
say 20 entries this is pointing at 21
okay I'm done no no entries all right
that makes sense this is the definition
so method lists you know will be X plus
1 but what happens if you have exactly
64 K minus 1 methods you know that
that's not gonna end up well because if
you add 1 to that what's gonna happen
you overflow and I said before like each
time you decide or add you know by sizes
and everything do I use 2 by 2 bytes for
representation or 4 bytes because I have
ffff methods how many bytes it is it's 2
bytes but now I'm supposed to index
something if the last type is empty
which is actually it requires 4 bytes so
what do you do with that so first of all
let's look at it actually at the you
know at the CEO ice pack which exactly
describes what it is
just like for reference and basically it
explains what I just said like you know
if you have less than not less than
equal or equal but less than 2 to 16
rows then you use of 2 bytes otherwise 4
bytes and by the way the method list is
from 1 because 0 even Tove your or
developers and we love zero based 0 is
now so that's forbidden so 1 2 rowcount
plus 1 and that's basically when you
look at that the problem that we
discovered is that in certain cases if
those two things collide you have as we
have back in the specification
how do you fix that well you don't that
the that the that's that kind of
narratives because fixing this back
means going change the specification
going chase down chase down and all the
old ecosystem all the profilers
debuggers Visual Studio Isle spy
reflector whatnot and go and back them
guys can you please change can you
please make this special case that if
it's this then do something else right
you know that's that's a lot of work
across the giveaway system so it's
extremely expensive and to take that
some perspective actually Macau who who
kind of investigated this because why do
I forgot to say that this is a story
from I think this this February or last
February so quite recent he said it
nicely like you know given that this
happens like once in seventeen years you
know maybe we don't have to fix that it
was actually the VIN RT team they
produced some venom these files and they
just happen to run in case that they had
the last type which was exactly that
ffff you know exactly the same number of
methods ran into that and the type was
empty now or didn't have didn't have any
metals it had maybe properties or fields
so the other thing that you can this you
know start thinking about it's like how
do you compensate for such a bug so we
ran through couple of you know
interesting things first of all you
could do you can start playing games and
really rearranging order of types as
soon as the last one is not the empty
one you're good well how would you like
it if you know if your compiler
sometimes changed order of your types as
you define them you know from the
deterministic way that's usually kind of
like not good so that's kind of nice to
think we kind of punted that the other
option actually was that to emit a fake
type at the end you know if you don't
like this situation exactly this kind of
overflow in a one-off I think let's
let's omit one fake type again how would
you feel if your compiler here and there
sometimes randomly injects new types and
then you start reflecting over that and
then you say like what the heck is this
right so again not a good thing the only
reasonable thing that we thought for or
is like if it's overflow you know what
let's use the zero you know
let's let it overflow let's use the zero
but suddenly you have to tell everyone
all that you know - sorry to change the
ecosystem products like forks yeah you
gotta you got to deal with that special
like it's not as obvious as you seem and
that's where we decided you know what
it's not worth to fix every single bug
especially if it's high frequency like
once per 17 years yeah so we decided to
punt it it's still actually open just in
case one day we might maybe fix it but I
don't think so
well we're we gonna wait another 17
years if we have one more hit maybe then
already that introduced us into
something you know or this type of fix
would be basically a breaking change
breaking change to many many tools many
existing kind of metadata readers and
things and breaking changes are
interesting topics topic on its own so I
would like to focus on that first
observation is that you know everyone
and I mean everyone in this room
everywhere you know when you have you
when you hit a buck especially in the
runtime or Windows the first thing that
you're gonna say like I want it fixed
it's a buck everyone does that it's
natural
right they're developers you find
something somewhere you're really proud
like yeah I found it but go fix it well
turns out nobody likes to be broken as
well and those two things kind of don't
work well together because what we
observed over time and this is kind of
quote from our one of our architects not
super super you know hard data but
roughly in ten percent one in ten
changes is gonna introduce some
unintended consequences no matter how
many code reviews how smart people
doesn't matter one in ten is gonna have
something unexpected now the question is
is it gonna be side effect that is okay
and minimal and nobody cares nobody hits
that or is it something that's gonna do
boom and those two things as I said like
everyone was there bug fix and but
nobody wants to be broken that's where
we especially kind of in the platform's
have to be extremely careful to which
bugs we you know we choose sorry which
bugs me fix we have to choose we have to
be kind of conscious of all the
potential consequences obviously the
people in the first cat
so if you find a bug like often I see on
github and everywhere people ask you
like but it's a bug like just just fix
it like oh it's not as simple and over
over my career actually run into one
extreme case and that was actually that
a pair of improvement broke a customer
you would say like you know what thing
that you know I'm I improved perf good
right and what happened I think it was
something around type loading or whatnot
you know he made some optimization and
turns out that there was one customer
something important that came back to us
that actually you know was relying
unintentionally obviously on this slow
speed because they relied on the order
how things are initialized they should
not but there's a reality right you know
so they relied on it they and when we
make things faster they got broken
because things got initialized in
different order they read something
before it was initialized so it was zero
boom their application stopped working
obviously it was some kind of like in
place update of dotnet framework so it
was probably not them no damn suffering
it was their customers and ever unhappy
to put it probably mildly what you do in
such you know situations you know if you
take this too extreme you should not
change anything which kind of sucks
right you know that that doesn't make
sense so in that case I believe that we
just said the right thing like yep sorry
you you basically had a back I know you
know it's not your fault that you do all
it's your fault kind of that you
dependent on time something that is kind
of not guaranteed but we understand but
you gotta change there's nothing you
know we're not going to beg helper for
improvements just because you had this
dependency on this and the key lesson
from these kind of things I have learned
over over time is that basically
everything has a risk of breaking
someone you know if it comes down to you
know making Parfum provement and I have
a couple of more fun stories on the
braking changes one is very interesting
well-built so it was it was end of
Windows 8 on arm and you know for it was
the I think it was the first surface RT
release or something like that and one
of the last builds you know v-final
suddenly started what happened is that
suddenly
finance application
crushing and obviously Microsoft you
know surface RT was a big thing back
then so you know application on the
first start fails the application team
was not happy to put it mildly and
eventually they came to us when they
kind of couldn't figure out it turned
out that it was actually a latent bug
that was there for months it was there
actually since beta time and was
interesting to find out what triggered
kind of triggered this bug and it was
there was two conditions first one was
that there had to be method in engine
images if you don't know what it is
ignore it
you know sterilized on the disk IOT
ahead of time compilation and it had to
be exactly you know if it was on on the
boundary of 8 kilobyte pages that was
one condition
the other condition that GC had to be
triggered twice while this was on the
call stack which means that the
application had to be under some stress
starting application you know that can
happen right you know application starts
lots of things happen you know on
multiple frets it happened in finance
and it was actually some kind of
networking for networking part and that
we found out that actually some totally
unrelated change somewhere just was
lucky enough to push this method of
default proxy which took enough time
that under stress was twice during GC on
the call stack and was unlucky to be on
the border of the eighth kilobyte pages
and big bada boom you broke you broke
finance application and the change I
don't know what it was we didn't track
it down but basically the outcome of
that is no matter what's change you know
if you say like oh this is the safest
change I look here like look like you
guy can prove you that this is right you
don't know what it's gonna cause farther
down the line
obviously we should not be that paranoid
even to sometime we should but the key
takeaway from that is like anything and
I mean literally anything has a risk of
breaking you know even I've heard
stories I didn't leave it for myself
even just triggering rebuild you know
even that can suddenly kick off you know
some latent bugs and stuff there has
been stories about that I don't have
them personally so again should you be
so scared not to do anything
probably not but those are
some of the things that sometimes you
have to consider and when you see and
hear on github or somewhere from us like
oh we don't gonna fix this because it's
the risk and you look at that it's
simple just like look at the code just
fix it right it's I can I can you know
prove it to you that is right like these
kind of stories and experiences come
from the other side for to our minds and
that's why sometimes we said politely
sorry yeah like no you're not gonna fix
it even though it's super simple of
course only if it's and your end of the
release the other kind of angle of the
breaking changes and stuff of fun fun
part is actually that they may have like
really huge impact and this is a story
that that actual I didn't live through
directly but that's it it kind of is a
very well-known on our team as a as a
poster child of like you shall not
change things at certain time and it was
actually patched to.net framework so
boom bust on all the two billion
machines or whatever days and certain
texts of church not gonna main kind of
name broke okay
the trouble was that the part that broke
was printing the text forms okay you
know not good
well the update was pushed right before
the text deadline in the US and when you
put those two things together it's like
oh my gosh you know that's not good
it wasn't good customers were unhappy it
was not just the text software it was
their customers who they kind of like
start printing you know one day before
deadline or a few hours I don't know how
you do Texas in Europe oftentimes the
employer does it for you I do then last
minute I'm a procrastinator I hate them
many people do and guess what if you
well I I do them online but back then
people probably you know sometime print
them and they cannot print their taxes
that's that's bad that's bad what was
funny you can look at it like oh you
maybe didn't test enough turns out we
did test that the text software company
test tested that scenario except we
printed everything into PDF we never
reused the printer because why would
your test pass always print out
something on the printer the buck was so
specific that it broke only printing on
the printer
yep tough luck so what was the lesson
learned from that
certain dates be careful
for example text season you know and
there might be other other parts for
example even end of the year and you
know these are this is old story this is
you know probably ten years old or
something like that but you see similar
things as well in for example online
shopping companies right there usually
before season their season like
Christmas is their time and they kind of
some have most sell in ourselves maybe
50% or 30% of their all volume they
basically stopped pushing anything into
production just to avoid any risk of
anything breaking so I have friends in
those companies or and they always like
yup I I cannot do anything until January
you know lockdown season which starts in
November so it's very similar what's
interesting on this that you see certain
similar patterns even in frameworks or
operating systems which is not quite
super intuitive at first sight but yep
we had interesting experience all righty
and now I'm gonna go through the you
know fun part
networking sure this is last story it's
sellable longer one it's a very dear to
me because I lived through that last
July it was lots of fun and because we
already pushed out the security fixes in
last August or something I can hopefully
talk about that and was it was very
interesting and eye-opening so this
story starts actually the story starts
nor denote more than in July last year
but it starts actually December before
just 2017 and in January there was some
kind of researcher running some ml for
clothes mining thing you know inside
Microsoft and on models and he used
cosmos I'm not sure it's cosmos now
public I think it is right yeah
so I processing lots of lots of data
large jobs and things and here and there
he got weird results and eventually they
got you know Frew cosmos and some kind
of couple of SDKs to us and to like this
is weird like he's getting like vir
responses for these requests so what's
the first response to that being trained
of like you know how people ask us for
various weird things that have nothing
to do with us first thing is like are
you sure it's on the client well I own
sorry our team back then or my team now
own sexually networking client side are
you sure it's on the client
it's not on the server because if you're
chasing down the server you know if
we're good
collecting logs from the client it's not
going to help us right you know we need
to find out very well the problem is you
know where it starts so they started
doing some kind of logging I think that
you deployed var shark because in
production & Kosmos that's that's not
fun so that you know lots of people and
eventually the proof or the Dvorak
traces and other traces prove that
actually it's you know server is fine
you know it gets the requests it sends
the right responses so something is
fishy on the client so I don't know many
were like okay yeah you might be
involved
so it's either us as a networking site
or something underneath us which is like
OS networking but you know when you're
on the on top of the stack to blame
guess what you gotta investigate so we
started investigation and it was already
kind of I think more uh February and so
we send them it should we were
suspicious about like we look at the
codes around like what could happen I
was like you know some kind of weird
buffers so I was like ya know that's
weird
we gave them actually some logging furs
they collected logs they were useless
obviously we didn't count it it was
something like this so we edit we
created private bills for them it like
special special logging points gave them
the private bills and then right it
turns out that you know after months we
ping them so what's up like do you have
deluxe for us that we can take a look at
that and it's like no it's gone the repo
is gone
like what am I gonna have you updated
two different cluster what no different
hardware and doesn't reproduce anymore
and even back then like the reproduce
reproduction was like you know once per
week you know the researcher kind of got
wrong results so I don't know how many
how many kind of data points he cracked
in but you know it was not quite you
know quite at so with that if you don't
have repro even though if you sis you
know you suspect something was really
fishy and well actually back then we
didn't know if it's just one machine I
know I didn't even get to ask that
question I believe or maybe I did then
they told me that probably multiple but
we were suspicious we probably knew it
is something fishy but now you have not
no leads basically I have nothing to do
so we kind of put it to ice and then in
May so two months later kind of similar
report comes and all the email and I was
interesting that I would one email and
like lots of people and like a we see
some big things be centric
and you know something wrong wrong comes
back what the heck you know it might be
networking team and when I looked at
that we actually we started looking at
that and roughly and slowly first like
okay you know guys did you check server
client and in two weeks suddenly blew up
because there was like multiple teams
like suddenly I know five or six teams
back then I actually realized suddenly
that the email in May actually it had
two teams on the and email they somehow
found each other they have the same
problem and came to us together and we
were I was not able to kind of decomp
you know D compost that information out
of the email it was you know you know
what's funny what kana and then we had
like roughly five five teams kind of
knocking on our door like hey something
fishy is happening so it was suddenly
all hands on deck situation because you
know when I'm gonna act and get to that
later but basically when you provide
different response to requests or
something like that
you know that that might have some
serious consequences we're gonna get to
that luckily it's team or the two teams
had like awesome thing they worked on a
repro like that's you know please and
whenever whenever you can work on small
repairs as small as possible so they had
like very simple thing and in twenty
minutes it was able to reproduce the
program then they kind of tweak some
parameters but not and in one minute you
had very Pro which is awesome it's
amazing makes life so much easier and on
top of that even the the best thing ever
gave are able to reproduce it under time
travel debugging if you don't know what
time travel debugging is it used to been
called I DNA and TTT or slightly
different technology similar go find out
it's only in windbg sorry but it's a
lifesaver like basically naively you can
think about it that the whole execution
of the program or part of it is recorded
instruction by instruction on each fret
the trouble is that is as you know the
recording has like eight X or 10x
overhead on the application so
oftentimes if you can reproduce
something you run it under TTD suddenly
doesn't reproduce because different
timing and things but as soon as you
catch it under under TTD you're golden
you're done like you know you
probe it's just a matter of time before
you get to that the beautiful on that on
the recording is that actually you you
are at the time that word error happened
you can set breakpoints data breakpoints
on read or write or breakpoints on
methods and you just say go back and it
reverts back the kind of you know
execution time and cell oops over here
it was triggered so when for example if
you remember the hardware back like the
bit flip right you know that wouldn't
probably show up but you know if if
there would be religiously or something
like flipping your bit you would just
set you know hey I have this data this
bit shouldn't be set like tell me who
wrote it or who wrote into this thing
you could just go back in the trace
which is just lifesaver
so with that we were able to kind of
root cause the issue into something that
was actually HTTP pipelining under
stress funny part was that was a 13
years old puck which all of the blue
started started kind of you know
reproducing and messing up with other
stuff if you don't know what HTTP
pipelining is I'm gonna do a quick intro
on that so classic HTTP is that you have
a request you send it to the server
server sends back bot response simple
right now if you imagine you it over and
over on you know you have multiple you
have several connections you don't you
usually don't have too many you know
default is to I believe inductance
framework sorry for that but if you have
like maybe hundred or something you have
basically limited pipeline or mean
limited kind of what is it called
limited by how to communicate with the
server if you want to reuse the same
connection for another request you have
to wait for the request which is kind of
time to server and back which takes time
so it's kind of slow so HTTP pipelining
introduces the thing that you can
actually own the connection you can send
multiple requests even if you don't get
the response yet and the server has to
send the responses in that order
simple right you just kind of avoid the
blocking on getting the response back
you you pipeline things kind of i-64
awful thing anyway when you get you know
what happens if you send for example
request one then request to before you
get answer then you get response one and
later on you get response too
life is beautiful you know it's
associated to the right things so what
was this back about the back was about
if you had at least three requests
pipeline on in connection and when
cancellation of requests was involved
time outs so it was the stress part you
know the system was so stressed you know
so overloaded that you know here and
there something was cancelled now if you
cancel the first request what do you do
whatever code it it did the right thing
it look at the you know at the
connection and said like well the first
response that comes back is going to be
to the request I don't care about
anymore so boom throw away the the
connection life is beautiful
now what if you would do it with request
number three and the last one the code
what it says like kind of natural exit
like look at it and like yep just like
listen to the first to you know throw
away this one and and Mark the
connection you know one once you're done
with with wit processing request just
close it
don't kill more you know again simple
you would get response one you would get
response to afterwards and then you
would just close the connection now the
trick came comes what if you can so the
request in the middle obviously we can
come up with you know right now from top
of head with the right tank probably
what should happen but that what the
code actually does it removed the
request from the queue looks kind of
innocent and kind of similar to what the
request freed it except that do you gain
that response one good the associate
with request to and then you get a
response to accept the response to its
associated with your request free boom
so in certain load situations we
associate the wrong response door Bronk
response with with with the request and
that can have multiple side effects as I
said for example imagine the request was
something I'm not gonna name it the
products affected but hey does this data
exists and answer should be no but you
get different response which is a yes go
on
you just lost data because you get wrong
wrong information imagine that it's
actually in an adverse divorce case it
was some multi-tenant
you know server something something
large that is multiple customers and the
request free was like give me data about
customer X and the response to was hey
here's data about customer Y that's not
that's not fun
it's kind of mixing mixing data and if
you mixing customer data it's now that
nobody wants that so that happened
I was also fun we had workaround for
that just disable pipelining luckily it
was it was present there it had some
perf impact because as I said the
pipelining was invented so to kind of
streamline I get more fruit but hey if
you have to choose between security
potentially be broken and being a bit
slower what do you choose I choose
slower or everyone saying yes right so
what they did that day that's what they
did we just cool and in parallel we
worked on a fix and we were verifying
the fix and repro after four hours fail
again with our fix and we we're like
what the heck is going on so you come
back and it was exactly the same
symptoms you send something you get the
wrong result and we just fixed that and
we were quite short like sure it was
cold archeology it was ancient code line
it actually for the first time our
expert was just you know on vacation you
know by a chance that happens and but
anyway you know we kind of looped in a
couple of experts who used to work
around that codebase and was like yeah
that sounds right you know when you
explain it this way so we were digging
what didn't help is that the repro what
we had was extremely sensitive actually
to work load on the in the cloud on the
network so I you know it was in July my
family was already in Europe so I worked
overtime because this was fun part and
it needed to get done and I couldn't rip
right in the UNIX I was like what the
heck is going on then a queue later we
found out that actually between 8 and 17
the load was exactly right it got the
right stress and these things reproduced
if you did it after hours boom you're a
pro is gone so that didn't help with
debugging by the way
so we tried again time travel debugging
because it's lifesaver
tough luck we were not lucky to catch it
under time travel debugging
so that didn't help us and we got again
suspicious you know we remembered our
suspicions from January so this is joy
helpful year earlier about the buffers
so like all we have these kind of
special logging let's try that and of
course we discovered that there was like
bad buffer lifetime management on the
sending side actually so we when we were
sending sending a request before it went
out we reuse the buffer for another
request and the other request wrote the
data into the payload and then this
request send it out so what ended up
actually the request for one server from
the other one got sent to another server
which was fun that's actually how we
first found out and you know about it as
well from production in parallel it
turned out that this buck was five years
old in the codebase since night four
five two interestingly it was introduced
at the time that I was perfect and you
know so it was basically under my
leadership which was funny so back then
it seemed to be like great tank and we
you know improve things for from
performance reason and didn't realize
that the buffer lifetime management is
not quite right so what what we were
then digging into was interesting to
final act so why why was this triggered
like what what happened like you know
why suddenly you know since four five
two until now which was four seven one
whatever version you know it nobody kind
of it wasn't trigger and luckily we had
Skype team who was amazing they
basically had they had ability to take
our private builds put them to
production they didn't care too much if
it kind of is all bit broken because
they had like creature eyes and think
and they said like yeah whatever like if
you go from one person failure to ten
percent good good
it was like I love it like you know when
you have when you have this type of like
I you know how's it like you know I
don't I don't test and when I do I do it
in production so yeah this was exactly
that so we love it because like when you
have this complicated repro and like you
know this type of thing
you know how do you you know how are you
sure even if you try to track it down on
your repro that's the real thing in
production and it was already second
buck right you know we are
fixed one and we discovered another one
so anyway with their with their kind of
help we figure out that actually it was
changed in four seven one that triggered
it
what was mind-blowing is first of all
the change that triggered this problem
was actually partial fix of this buck so
there was something basically imagine
that you start you know in main method
you start and if we go when went then
down and hold on the buffer and the the
kind of the change in four seven one was
that we moved oh you know what let's
release the buffer here the right change
that we did actually but this was all
release it even higher so you could view
it that like oh we kind of created the
window when the buffer could be reused
was like smaller you'll figure you know
it was smaller yet suddenly triggered
somehow the issue fun times and so to
make it even more interesting through
code reviews we couldn't hit this in in
the repro we actually found out we have
similar type of bug of a lifetime
management on the not on the sending
side but on the receiving side and it
was introduced the same kind of at the
same time it was entirely different code
different principle but the lifetime was
just not right so that was the most fun
thing because you know basically you
find out that they're you sound out of
the blue you hit two issues probably
free which have same symptoms and they
are kind of independent at the same time
so first question we asked like you know
hey you know why so many customers or
services and actually we counted what we
did actually we didn't talk with a bunch
of a bunch of teams in Microsoft and
asked them like that you hit that you
hit this and they went through their
logs and most of them like yeah you know
what that's the 0.01% of our failure
rate could be this because it had
certain signature I forgot what it was
like 404 or something but it was under
the threshold that they care about and
suddenly out of the blue you know
multiple services were hit by this this
heart and you know the only the best
thing that economists we came up it that
it was kind of after the spectra
meltdown which had some kind of impact
on performance fixes in OS and that's
the best thing
that we can kind of kind of imagine we
even tried like you know afterwards like
you know various things you know how it
triggers doesn't trigger why why this
and we couldn't come up with anything so
into that or basically just magic you
know I started believing in magic so
lesson lesson learned from this is like
like weird coincidences can happen like
you know three bucks at the same time or
two to free you know I don't know I
still cannot process that fully alright
that's roughly about it so I'm gonna
wrap it up and I want to kind of review
the lessons that we learned today
hopefully you know the key takeaways
that you guys can have folks so first of
all we went further like always a score
at least from our sides or don't be
surprised when we do does it repro only
on one machine and you know if you think
that you're just stalling or not we're
protecting ourselves from the extremely
expensive investigation and costly and
yeah it's at the cost that you have to
try it on another machine when you hit
the back but you know at the end of the
day life is better because debugging
hardware hardware issues if it comes to
that is extremely costly some bugs
happen only once per 17 years should we
fix them or not that's a good question
spec bugs are extremely hard to fix
because the impact in the meta data
format if you saw across the across the
you know ecosystem would be nightmare
luckily it was the once in 17 years so
we could kind of downplay it but imagine
it would be more often it's raw and if
it's roll out rolled out expect suddenly
becomes problematic I don't think you
know anything really anything has risk
of breaking someone so that was the
story about the light and back all 8k
eight kilobytes things that you know in
something entirely unrelated can trigger
bucks so just be careful about that or
or be prepared for fun times and
sometimes the impact can be really huge
was the you know text seasoned thinking
and one thing if I if I if you can come
up with this from this talk with one
learning I would ask like always try to
create small repros that by the way if
you ever saw me on github
encore effects like that that's the
first times you're gonna get from me
like do you have a small repro give me
minimal repro oftentimes people say like
but I don't have time for that I was
like do I have time to debug your whole
application like know like you know try
to create small repro obviously it's not
always possible you know but you see
that some you know one of the stories
was actually the networking like the
people are able to get small reports
just you know so much easier to debug
without this small repro I think it
would take us two months handful you
know hands on something against
something that we could pull off in less
than week right so having small Reaper
not having is like very huge you know
change and you're gonna make your life
easier you're gonna make everyone Li's
life easier even though it's some
investment it costs something but it
just worth it other thing you know if
you can look up the TTD time travel
debugging I highly recommend that if you
run into some of these cool crazy things
you know it's my safe it's it's a
lifesaver like or time saver as well
obviously and the key takeaways I think
that sometimes there's just magic you
know you just you know there's no
explanation when things happen like that
and at certain point as ng engineers we
want to understand everything obviously
but sometimes SEC you know what I I I
tried hard enough I give up
it's fixed or whatever we have work
around let's move on right thank you
very much I would like to ask you for
feedback after days I don't know why I
made it this way sorry now you see
everything hopefully you enjoyed to talk
you know if you have feedback hit me on
DM on twitter email or over here in
person I would love to hear like you
know what you liked what you didn't like
was it too rushed actually I ended up 10
minutes 10 minutes beforehand which is
awesome I didn't expect that if
something was hard to understand boring
core whatnot I love feedback that helps
me and as you see in the tweet which I
did actually yesterday you know there
are more you know apply this to other to
other speakers as well
speakers love feedback because that's
the only way how we can get better so
thank you very much
[Applause]